So now let's ask the question, how can we use the filtering mechanisms that
we have looked at so far to find interesting features in an image?
So here, for an example, are the two images.
You may recall them from the instance of the panorama building experiment or
exercise we did earlier.
And we want to be able to take these two images.
You know, one this image here and that image.
And actually for this case, for just sake of, let's say building a panorama,
we want to be able to find features that are similar in between those things.
Then we can do things like alignment.
So in this case what I'm interested in is finding information that's
similar in both of them.
Here I've basically created about one, two, three, four,
five circles that kind of point to specific features or information in
this image, and again the same five features are available in this image.
Again, if you remember, this was a pan camera motion from this to that.
So there were two different images of course.
And you can notice that there are different images,
except that they have a little bit of overlap.
And of course what we want to do is find the same feature in both of them.
Here I've just drawn the lines between them pointing out the correspondence that
this same point here is also visible here, that one is visible here, and so on.
So to achieve this process of being able to then align these two images, or
find different things that are similar in them so then we can actually register
them together, we need to extract some sort of higher level features.
So one of the biggest advantages of mapping or
extracting these features from an image is it allows us to
map these raw pixels into an intermediate representation.
Which basically means, is that now we can basically take an image,
extract those features, and not actually be looking at the image any more, but
just those features.
Such an intermediate representation allows us to have,
to have a lot of information but also kind of reduce the amount of data.
Because what I would just do is, after a while, process this image,
find all those 5 or maybe sometimes 20 different features.
And 20 different features in here,
and basically just attach that information and
not anymore require me to carry around the image or the information in there.
So this is of course a kind of a data preservation in of information,
which we can use for a variety of things.